the turbulence of the trump
administration has left a slew of former
appointees and officials in its wake
while these folks for any number of
reasons couldn't weather the storm
attorney general bill barr has hung on
taking each crisis as an opportunity to
assert himself
the president has not attempted to
interfere in these decisions
on the contrary he has told me from the
start that he expects me to exercise my
independent judgment to make whatever
call i think is right and that is
precisely what i've done
he saw an opportunity to come back into
a position where he would have a lot of
power
a lot of sway within a chaotic
administration
he had an agenda that he wanted to carry
forward from his time as previous
attorney general
what remains to be seen with criticism
and controversy reaching a fever pitch
is how it will all turn out will his
fervent support of executive power
buttress further presidents and
attorneys general for years to
come or will he for the second time in
his life
hit a dead end and be jettisoned from
office along with the other members of
another one-term presidency
william barr was born in 1950 to parents
donald and mary margaret
both professors at columbia university
after going to elite schools corpus
christi and horace mann
bill attended columbia himself where he
got his bachelor's and master's degrees
in 1989 he was appointed by george h.w
bush to the office of legal counsel
where he began writing opinions
supporting broad powers for the
president and the executive branch
including for the u.s invasion of panama
and subsequent arrest of manuel noriega
in 1991 barr was promoted from deputy
attorney general to acting attorney
general
a few weeks after that president bush
officially nominated barr to the
position of aj
barr sailed to confirmation with
bipartisan support
including that of someone who would call
for his resignation
28 years later but i personally like you
i think you're a heck of an honorable
guy
i think you're press someone i can work
with and you've demonstrated that
when i say can work with i don't mean
you do it our way i mean you
when you sit down and negotiate you
genuinely negotiate
the new york times in 1992 described the
central theme of his tenure
as a contention that violent crime can
be reduced by expanding federal and
state prisons
to jail habitual offenders to this end
he authored a report
the case for more incarceration a study
in 1999 called it overly simplistic
and a university of minnesota
criminologist has said its data is
deceptively presented however barr is
far from the only public servant
responsible for the growth in
incarceration since his time in office
the u.s prison population has about
doubled and the u.s has the most
incarcerated people of any country
in the world after finishing his first
run as attorney
general he spent two and a half decades
in the private sector
working for a phone company that you may
have heard of can you hear me now
good he worked for
verizon and its predecessor company gte
where he was general counsel and he
spent about 15 years at those companies
as they effectively consolidated the
telecommunications industry he is fairly
unique
for an attorney general because
he came to the job with a pretty
extensive
background in corporate america
cut to early 2019 after driving jeff
sessions out as attorney general and the
mueller investigation soon coming to a
conclusion
trump figured he could use a strong
advocate i think that
the the probe is a disaster for our
country
when trump fired sessions there was a
small group of
establishment conservatives
establishment republicans who
took it upon themselves to go and find
somebody who could be
an acceptable attorney general barr had
already
gotten on the radar of trump in the
white house because
he wrote an unsolicited letter
criticizing the mueller investigation
well before he was considered to be you
know for the attorney general position
but why decades later did he want the ag
job again
i'm almost 70 years old i was almost 70
years old and slipping happily into
retirement
i had nothing to prove and i had no
desire to return to government
he saw an opportunity to
re-establish the power of the executive
branch
bars justice department you know has
played a central role
in uh defending the administration and
defending the white house
i don't think that his methodology and
beliefs have changed
so much as his actions have changed
under the bush administration in in the
early 90s
there was a much more of an
institutional framework
and a policy making framework under
which
barr operated and was and was
constrained trains kind of ran on time
under the trump administration a lot of
that has disintegrated it's a lot of
chaos
and now he has much more uh leeway
in terms of what he can do bar was
confirmed
this time on a near party line vote in
february of 2019
a month later he set the tone for his
time in office
releasing a four-page letter on the
mueller report
investigation did not establish that
members of the trump campaign conspired
or coordinated
with the russian government in its bar
mischaracterized
the findings of the muller report it was
a four-page summary
the mauler report was 500 pages with
detail after detail
of interactions and contacts between the
trump campaign
and russians and the mueller report also
concluded that the trump campaign
actively sought out russian assistance
and welcomed russian assistance
and the the muller report also found
that there were at least 10
examples where trump obstructed justice
now barr didn't
provide any of this information in his
summary
and barr put his summary out about a
month before the mueller report became
public
even mueller himself wrote bar a letter
saying that he mischaracterized
mueller's findings
it was the greatest hoax ever
perpetrated on the people of this
country
and you know what i am so proud of our
attorney general
that he is looking into it i think it's
great in the aftermath
barr also ordered that charges against
michael flynn be dropped
and that the recommended sentence for
roger stone be reduced
trump later commuted his sentence anyway
in more recent days
barr has used the power of his office in
more forceful ways
in early june he ordered the removal of
protesters near the white house
leading to acts of violence against what
was a largely peaceful crowd
president trump was subsequently able to
conduct this now famous photo op
then about a month later i'm just here
to do my job
barr also unceremoniously attempted to
oust manhattan u.s attorney jeffrey
berman
barr just announced that berman was
going to step down and
hours later berman issued a statement
saying he wasn't going to step down
next day barr said that he had talked to
trump and berman was going to be fired
and berman
at that point negotiated a situation in
which his deputy
would take over leading the the u.s
attorney's office
the reason why this is so controversial
is because that u.s attorney's office
has been
investigating actions by trump and and
actions by trump's associates
as we look to the future barr looks to
make more waves that benefit the man who
appointed him
one of the more amusing aspects of
modern progressive
polemic is their breathless attacks on
the
unitary executive theory
immediately after president trump won
election opponents inaugurated what they
called
the resistance and they rallied around
an explicit strategy of using every tool
and maneuver to sabotage the functioning
of the executive branch and his
administration
a number of the cases that barr has
personally involved himself in
are also cases that trump wants to
have his attorney general be involved in
now barr will say that that's just doing
impartial justice in terms of
approaching these different cases
the biggest investigation that barr
ordered is a investigation into
the fbi's uh probe into trump's campaign
and uh and trump associates uh related
to russian interference in the 2016
election now that's interesting because
then that puts it right as the election
this year is heating up we potentially
have a situation
where bar and the justice department are
going to start to roll out
uh findings that um undercut
things that were done by the obama
administration and by virtue things that
were done
under the obama biden administration and
it'll be stuff that
trump and his conservative allies most
likely will seize on and use to their
advantage
[Music]
you